prime minister hello good evening go on
with 40 of your mps against you so well
i think this is a
a very good result for for politics and
for uh for the country justin it's just
i i do just in this sense i think it's a
convincing result a decisive result on
what it what it means
is that as uh
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people i think it's a decisive result
and your allies wanted her to go
straight away how how is this different
how can you possibly continue this is a
i've got a far bigger
mandate from my own parliamentary
colleagues for instance than i had in
2019
and
had a pretty good mandate
she had to go with it
i'm grateful to colleagues i'm grateful
for
the support they've given me and of
course i understand that what we need to
do now is come together
as a as a government as a party
and that is exactly what we can now do
and what this gives us is the
opportunity to put behind us
all the stuff that i know the uh the
media have quite probably wanted to
focus on for a very long time
and to do our job which is to focus on
uh the stuff that i think the public
actually want us to be talking about
which is what we are doing to help
the people of this country and all the
things we're doing to take this country
forward and so so what this means
tonight is that we can focus on exactly
that we can focus on what we're doing to
help people with the cost of living
with what we're doing to clear the code
with what we're doing to make
streets and communities safer by putting
more police out
and
it gives us the opportunity to continue
to unite to level up
to strengthen our economy we're going to
go through a continuing uh difficult
time because of the inflationary
pressures that the world is experiencing
but we have a lot of a lot of natural
strength not least the lowest
unemployment since 1974 and
what i think is important about tonight
and
you know forgive me i'm going to say it
again i think this is very good news
because it allows the government to
focus on on those issues and that's what
you say you want to focus on those
issues 148 mps on your own side are
against you they're going to be dragging
you through the mud how can you possibly
govern with it
you really think that's a good result
it's a good result i certainly think it
is because don't forget that uh you know
when i first stood to be uh leader of
the conservative party in 2019 i didn't
get anything like uh that much uh
support from my my colleagues in poland
uh were
doing that and uh what we have now is an
opportunity to put behind us all the
stuff as i say that uh
people in the media like going on about
and i think the there's a difference in
in the category of conversation
i know you know people want to talk
about stuff that goes on at westminster
what i want to talk about is what we as
a government are doing so you need to
help all those entities and no what
we're going to do now is take the
opportunity to unite and deliver and
that is that's what we want to do are
you ruling out a snap election is that
not the only way forward to stop you
from being lamed up what we want to do
uh is to get on
use this moment which i think is
whatever you may say i think is is
decisive and conclusive and continue
with our priorities and and i think
those are
those ruling out
we are going through a period when we
have to help people with the cost of
living and we are 1200 pounds for 8
million of the most vulnerable
households in the country plus a lot of
other support 500 400 pounds to
absolutely absolutely everybody with the
uh with the cost of energy the only
reason we can do that is because we have
a robust economy
unemployment the lowest level for for 50
years that is the
those are the things that really matter
to our country right now and uh yeah i
am
pleased because we now have the chance
to talk exclusively
about
those priorities and not about uh
all sorts of stuff that i know is of
obsessive and compulsive interest uh to
uh my beloved friends in the media but i
don't think really
matters as much as the agenda of the
government so you're in a worse position
than theresa may was after her vote in
2018 and you think this is a good result
i think it's an extremely good
positive conclusive decisive result
which enables us
to move on uh to
unite and to focus on delivery and that
is exactly what we're going to do and to
confirm you're ruling out a snap so you
keep asking about you know look this is
nice
i'm certainly have no
i see no point in focusing on anything
else and i'm certainly not interested in
uh in in snap elections what i'm
interested in is delivering right now
for the people of this country we've got
an amazing agenda we are we we have a
fantastic mandate uh a huge uh uh
biggest majority we secured in 2019 for
the conservatives for for 40 years uh i
if you look at what's just happened in
uh import whatever statistics you want
to chuck around i've got many more mps
supporting me now than i did in 2019 i'm
happy with that we're going to bash on
uh we have a huge agenda and we're going
to get it done so you still think you're
a popular prime minister in the party
and in the
country can i just say i think the most
important thing
although you may want to focus on me and
on politics and on uh on westminster i
think what matters is what we deliver
and what we
do and as a result of this uh decision
tonight by the parliamentary party which
i welcome uh we have a conclusion uh to
something that's been dragging on for
far too long and we have the ability now
to unite deliver and get on with the
people's priorities and that is what
we're going to do okay thank you thank
you